he's got to get off it though he's got
to get anybody else
what
oh my God he can't be no way Tim what's
wrong with that shot guys
what was wrong with that side hold on
now
can I see it again
where did he take that from
what do you want to do take a dribble
talk just 10 seconds left in the game
but what if you're not gonna get a
better shot than that you gonna be this
look at this no contest look at this
is
get off the Henny I can no no no
way I'm being sick the sick if they lose
this one which they're gonna you know
what that is that's analytics you think
because
not one bit he doesn't like that shot
yeah I mean Jordan was like I had the
hot hand I was having a good game
he's wide open duck
from that far away with not with 10
seconds and you you have an advantage
I'm shooting it I'm shooting that if I'm
Jordan so I feel you Jared I would have
shot that too that's why you here with
us
[Applause]
he gonna be here
I'm gonna shoot that shot in the playoff
game next year yeah I hope you do
this is for you
I'm gonna be doing this like a TT
looking teacher